the traditional summer job is quickly
fading as a rite of passage for American
teenagers in the summer of 1978 60% of
teens either worked or looked for work
by last summer that fell to only 35
percent Derrick Thompson of the Atlantic
recently wrote about the reasons why
joins us now good morning happy Earth
before so we've learned your first
summer job was as a tennis instructor
but that's not the area of expertise
you're focusing on you've given your
right in this article about several
reasons why and one of them is education
why is education hurting teen work yeah
I think there's this sense that when you
look at the statistics it seems like
kids are just being lazy right teenagers
used to work during the summer and now
they're not but in fact if you look at
the numbers that 25 percent more of
these teens are entering college and
that 25 percent is exactly the drop in
the number of teens who are working
summer jobs so it appears to be a
relatively one-for-one switch they're
less likely to work summer jobs but
they're more likely to study to take
summer classes to take unpaid
internships which the government doesn't
count as a job because it is in fact
unpaid and so they are keeping busy
they're just investing in their future
investing their college education rather
than working for that near minimum wage
so is that a good thing the fact that
they're in the classroom I think it's a
good thing there's all sorts of studies
that seem to suggest that there are
students soft skills that you learn when
you do a summer job that it can help you
sort of build a sense of responsibility
but educate investing in your education
is also responsible and there's all
sorts of evidence that suggests that
people who go to and finish college are
much more likely to make more money and
be happy in their careers so I see this
is not an altogether bad thing I think
it's a positive development it's a good
problems you can afford it right I mean
a lot of kids you know you're not making
a ton of money but some kids have to
work to make that money do business
businesses still want to hire them
though they're just not necessarily the
kids want to want to pursue the
education instead yeah well there's two
interesting things happening at the
macroeconomic level first you have an
increase in low-skilled immigration and
an increase in older workers working and
they are they tend to take a lot of
these jobs like in retail or in you know
leisure and hospitality that used to be
sort of the province of teens during the
summer the second thing that's happening
is that the minimum way
age has increased a little bit recently
and some people think that there might
be a job that you'd give a 17-year old
for say five dollars an hour but when
the minimum wage does say ten fifteen
dollars an hour you say okay I'm not
going to hire a teenager to work this
job you know you mentioned retail we've
seen a decline in actual
brick-and-mortar stores has that had an
impact also on the number that we're
seeing working
yeah which definitely had an impact to
the number of retail workers the US
economy has lost 80,000 retail jobs
since October of last year that's more
than the total number of steel workers
in America so you have enormous
disruption happening in retail and I
wouldn't rule that out now it's my first
summer job
stick around retail because Jeff's first
job was making sandwiches he's gonna
Derek dog said thank you for joining us
right thank you